Ok, Fermium, it has absolutely no use as far
as anyone knows except
that it’s extremely radioactive. It’s
named after Enrico Fermi who is a
well-known physicist.
Fermi was an Italian physicist who in the
1930s was the first person to
discover artificial radioactivity. This is
where neutrons, which had only
recently been discovered when they did these
experiments, hit an
element that is not radioactive, increase
the weight of the nucleus but
not the number of protons and cause it to
fall apart by radioactive
decay.
And it also, like Einsteinium, where it was
first found in the debris of a
nuclear bomb, in fact the very first nuclear
bomb that was ever tested.
Shortly after the fascists took power in Italy,
Fermi moved to the United
States and, as part of the Manhattan project
for building the atomic
bomb, he built the first nuclear reactor under
the football stadium, in the
squash courts under the football stadium at
Chicago University, the
University of Chicago, right in the centre
of Chicago, and they filled the
squash courts with blocks of carbon with holes
in the middle through
which they put rods of uranium. So the first
ever sustained nuclear
reaction took place in the sports field of
University of Chicago and if you
go now there, the stadium itself has been
completely demolished, but
there’s a rather fine monument to the birth
of the atomic era.